bradwick ax
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening good evening and welcome to
the Hudson library and Historical
Society thank you for coming out tonight
my name is Polly Reynolds and I am head
of adult services and archives here at
the library just a few quick
announcements before we get started I
just want to let you know that c-span is
filming tonight for book TV just a
reminder so please silence your cell
phones and during the question and
answer we will be passing a microphone
so if you could wait for the microphone
before asking your question that would
be very helpful following the program
there'll be a reception and book signing
in the library rotunda just head back
out these doors and head back into the
library and there'll be refreshments and
you can get your book signed meet the
author I hope you'll join us I'm very
honored to introduce tonight's guest
author Brad Rica who will discuss his
latest book mrs. Sherlock Holmes the
true story of New York City's greatest
female detective and the 1917 missing
girl case that captivated a nation ricca
is also the author of super boys The
Amazing Adventures of Jerry Siegel and
Joe Shuster the creators of Superman
named a top 10 book on the arts by book
list and won the 2014 Ohio Anna Book
Award for nonfiction his poetry
collection American Mastodon was the
winner of the 2009 st. Lawrence Book
Awards in 2014 he was awarded a
Cleveland Arts Prize for emerging
artists in literature ricca teaches at
Case Western Reserve University as a
Stages fellow please join me in
welcoming Brad brick
[Applause]
thanks Polly and thanks Hudson library
for inviting me out and to c-span for
coming out to and most importantly to
all of you for coming out on this gray
and Misty evening which is really
perfect for for the things we're going
to talk about for gloom and doom and
murder and despair we're going to talk
true crime today and I have a confession
to make this is a detective book in so
many ways a mystery book is that I
really hate true crime and I know hate
is one of those words you know I know my
mom told me never we don't hate anything
but I really hate true crime and it it
goes back to I think a lot of different
places but I know I worked at a
bookstore after college and and you go
by the true crime section which I avoid
it at all cost and there's those little
mass-market paperbacks with those men
staring out at you and they're always
black and red like Soviet propaganda
posters and they're awful and if you
happen to just open one up and you see
the pictures the photos and they're even
worse now we thought how unfair to have
a book that you open up and see things
like this and I'm not judging you if you
like true crime I think that's great I
will never judge someone on the kind of
books they like I like comic books but I
hate true crime at the same time there's
something about it and you grow older
that doesn't go away so even though we
put it in the back corner of every
bookstore you know it's always this
really short shelf and it's always hard
to find we don't want to acknowledge it
but it's still there
true crime is real you have genres like
six
like poetry like nonfiction which I'm
not sure what that word even means
anymore either but true crime is what it
is
when you read a true crime book and it
says the word
death it says the word murder that word
is real it's not an imagined character
so it has an extra weight to it
true crime is always at the door where I
live in Cleveland every Wednesday we get
a coupon circular in the mail I'm sure
some of you get this too and you open it
up and it's on newsprint and there's all
these these coupons for things like
frozen peas or or a magical hose that
somehow you know zips up and is flexible
but on the last page of the of the
circular there's always this little
pictures anyone else get this a little
photo of someone who has disappeared
yeah and it's not always a woman or a
girl but nine times out of ten it is and
it will give the person's name the date
they disappeared and sometimes it was a
month ago sometimes it was 20 years ago
and sometimes it has that awful photo
next to it the computer aged version
that looks like it was some bizarre
watercolor where they're smiling somehow
and we know they're not smiling so even
though I hate true crime I respect it
and as I grew older and I'm just kind of
telling you where the book came from I
would get those things in the mail and
wonder you know how how does it come to
this that when someone disappears we get
information about it through the mail
with coupons for spinach peas and hoses
and then we put it we look at it we look
at the picture we decide we don't know
the person and then just put it away or
throw it away or use one of the coupons
for fifteen cents off the frozen peas I
don't like frozen peas either so I'm not
sure why I'm using that as an example
but how has how do missing people
missing girls missing women how they
come something that is so digestible
to us and that's one thing I was really
interested in kind of as a person as a
writer and you know writers often feel
kind of powerless about things you know
we're not in law enforcement or or in
positions of power all the time but
there's ways to work out these ideas in
the writing so that's what I really
wanted to write about this idea of how
has it come to this with with missing
girls in 21st century America so I went
looking for a story because I didn't
really have a story to tell about this
but I knew there had to be a story out
there that could get at these issues for
me so even though I hated true crime
there had to be a story out there that
would do it that's when I met grace
Humiston I didn't actually meet her
because she lived a hundred years ago
but I was doing research on an Italian
crime organization which is you know
that's something a writer would say well
it was Saturday and I was doing research
on an Italian crime organization and I
was going through an old copy of the New
York world which is an old newspaper and
looking for information on this
organization called the black hand and I
read some article and it sounded you
know pretty much all made up so I was
just clicking through the pages and all
of a sudden I saw this picture and it
was a woman I'm a middle-aged woman and
she was like this sir so she was in the
detective pose and the headline read
mrs. Sherlock Holmes has done it again I
said mrs. Sherlock Holmes I don't know
mrs. Sherlock Holmes
I love Sherlock Holmes so I read the
article and I couldn't believe what I
was seeing that there was a woman in New
York City who was as I found out in
subsequent research extremely famous in
fact for a time she was the most famous
detective in New York City arguably the
most famous detective in America and she
was called mrs. Sherlock Holmes and her
main mission in life was to find missing
girls so I knew there was
my story when I knew there was true
crime ominous and scary and real but
that's why we should write about it
because it is ominous and scary and real
because it is just outside the door so
I'm going to read a little from the book
and it's mostly one chapter I'm going to
read and there'll be no spoilers and I
say there's no spoilers because I don't
think of this book as a biography and a
biography you can't really have spoilers
for a biography biography is kind of
like the Titanic you know you know
someone's born they kind of do stuff and
then they you know die yeah everyone
knows the ending to a biography but this
I don't think of as a virus II I mean I
never wrote it as a biography her name
isn't even in the title and that's by
design and it's not really a true crime
book because like I said I'm not a huge
fan of true crime it's a mystery
I wrote it as a mystery and I wrote it
as a mystery because it is a mystery
this woman grace Humiston whom you're
going to hear about we don't know that
much about her so once I realized that
we couldn't find all the details of her
life she became like the missing persons
she looked so hard for so I'm going to
read a little bit of this I'm going to
give you some context on her but I'm not
going to give you any spoilers and
you'll find out why because there's one
the book itself is I wrote it also like
a case book so I love Sherlock Holmes
you know growing up you know you read
that first story and then someone tells
you there's more and you say how many
you know how soon can I read them and
then when you finally read them all
you're devastated but the thing I love
about the Holmes stories is they're all
cases and the cases come first and we
really don't even know that must much
about Sherlock he just kind of you know
does his thing but his personal life is
very much in the background and you only
get these little ten
and clues like wait Sherlock's doing
drugs what's happening so I kind of
wrote the book like that as a casebook
of her most interesting cases and there
are many I left out that these were the
big ones so that's my introduction I'm
going to read you part of the mystery
that is mrs. Sherlock Holmes there was
important news on the front page that
day but it was the photograph of a girl
in a white dress that made people stop
and stare appearing just below the
headline the young woman was not famous
but she certainly looked familiar
she was seated with her hands at her
side her dark hair pulled up and back
topped off by a great white bow she was
seated with her hands on her side she
smiled out past the stories of u-boat
attacks and President Woodrow Wilson her
face blurred by gray halftone dots Ruth
Krueger was 18 years old when she
appeared on the front page of the New
York Evening world on the day after
Valentine's Day 1917 she had been
missing for two days
Ruth had left her family's apartment on
the previous Tuesday to have her ice
skates sharpened when she didn't come
home her family called the police
detectives tramped through the snow and
rapped on doors they tracked down rumors
of a secret boyfriend and talked to
witnesses who said they saw her stagger
into a mysterious taxicab but these
Clues led nowhere
the owner of the motorcycle shop where
Ruth had picked up her skates an Italian
named Alfredo Kochi led detectives let
detectives search his store until they
were satisfied as the snow melted and
weeks turned into months the police
concluded that Ruth had probably just
eloped with an unknown suitor Ruth's
father Henry didn't like that he wrote a
pointed letter to the mayor then he held
a press conference
in front of reporters representing many
of Gotham's nearly 20 daily newspapers
Henry Krueger a short bald accountant
told all of New York City that his
daughter was a good girl and Hutton had
unquestionably been kidnapped
Henry's wife and two other daughters
stood beside him their eyes red and wet
perched behind them all was an older
woman wearing a black dress with a
matching hat that swept down her neck
like a sick old bird she looked to be in
her 50s and was presumed to be the
missing girl's grandmother apparently
already grieving so when Henry Krueger
introduced this woman this woman in
black as the family's new lawyer and
primary investigator the reporters were
surprised when she snapped forward and
demanded that from now on all Clues be
given directly to her her name was mrs.
grace Humiston and for the work she was
about to do on the sensational Krueger
case facing off against corrupt police
an unseen criminal society the
insatiable New York media and a
mysterious pale man reporters would give
her the singular moniker of mrs.
Sherlock Holmes in two short months
grace Humiston would become the most
famous female detective in America in
less than a year she would disappear
born in 1869 69 with a claim to old New
York money grace her name then Winterton
went to Hunter College before embarking
on what she thought would be a long
teaching career at the all voice
Collegiate School on the Upper West Side
after she was married her husband dr.
Henry Quackenbush was accused of
peephole practices at his office grace
divorced him quit her job and enrolled
in an evening class at the NYU School of
Law the only school in the city that
admitted women seated in the front row
she graduated in two short years ranked
seventh in her class around this time
she also began to wear black after a
short stint at the Legal Aid Society she
passed the bar and opened the people's
Law Firm the woman in black began to get
an almost legendary reputation among the
New York immigrant poor she challenged
government deportations helped underage
child workers who weren't being paid at
their jobs and even recovered lost
jewels for a grateful foreign ambassador
after winning a highly publicized appeal
that saved the life of a young Italian
mother who killed a man who was trying
to rape her grace became known as the
people's friend and was soon one of the
busiest lawyers in the city she then
noticed a disturbing pattern of young
men going missing and followed the clues
all the way to Florida where she
uncovered a system of forced slavery
through debt 40 years after the close of
the Civil War she reported and this was
a plantation she found in Arkansas was
an island and it was called Sunnyside
and it was effectively a slave
plantation 40 years after the Civil War
had ended using Italian immigrants and
the cotton company would lure Italian
and would lure these people from Italy
saying come to America we'll give you a
job and they had them sign all the
paperwork and they of course couldn't
speak English and they were really
signing their lives away because it was
a system of debt that they could not get
out of that they literally had to work
until they died and were buried on the
plantation so it was a loophole for
these very unscrupulous and evil cotton
plantation owners to get cheap labor
labor after the Civil War and she
uncovered this she infiltrated the camp
in disguise selling scissors and it was
a big case for her after testifying
before Congress and making front page
news with the Sunnyside case grace
returned to New York and once again
through her
often in the strange and unusual cases
that somehow always found their way to
her desk she fought against the same
doctor who tormented the famous reporter
Nellie Bly when she went undercover at
an insane asylum and was marked for
death by the sinister black hand the
Italian crime organization that used
secret codes and mystical rituals
eventually one of Graces rich society
friends mrs. Felix Adler called to tell
her that a girl had gone missing in New
York and begged her to meet with the
father of the girl one mr. Henry Krueger
by the time greats agreed to take the
case Ruth's Krueger's photo had appeared
in newspapers all over the country her
image even flickered in front of movie
theater audiences the press drawn to the
story of a pretty Sunday school teacher
who had vanished openly suspected white
slavery foul play and romantic
entanglement sometimes all in the same
story
juicy clues were flooding the detective
precincts but none of them panned out
but grace took a different approach to
the case she locked herself in her
office for a week to study every scrap
of paper related to it grace had been
trained as a lawyer but her inability to
trust the police
or even the law itself had over the last
few years turned her into more of a
detective now at age 48 her formula was
to search for clues herself verify them
and use them in the courtroom to make
her arguments Shin trust the police so
she effectively just found her own
evidence in this case grace kept coming
back to Alfredo Kochi the man who had
sharpened Ruth's skates since being
questioned by detectives coachy had also
disappeared though most of his neighbors
speculated he simply feared being made a
scapegoat for the crime especially
because he was Italian the police it
seemed could blame his people for
anything in those days and it's true at
this time the everyone blamed the
Italians if anything was was
mentally related they'll just blame the
Italians but though Cochise plates had
already been searched his motorcycle
shop was the last place Ruth had been
seen grace wanted to see it herself this
is how grace ended up standing in the
middle of Manhattan Avenue in Harlem and
staring up at the Metropolitan
motorcycle shop in June of 1917 grace
craned her neck and took in the tall
glass windows that ran almost 10 feet
high across the front of the store the
white lettering across the glass red
motorcycles storing on the left and auto
supplies on the right she saw ten signs
for Mobil Oil that hung still in the air
a single globe lamp hung off a pole in
front of the entrance and a huge
billboard for graham crackers as big as
long as the shop itself rose off the
roof and into the blue sky the inside of
cochise shop was dim behind the smoked
glass maria kochi Alfredo's wife had
been left behind and was now when her
husband disappeared and was now
desperately trying to keep the store
afloat she had two small children Maria
who claimed to have no knowledge of
where her husband was had refused any
further searching of the premises the
police were no help either as grace
moved from desk to desk in city
buildings trying to gain entrance to the
score to the store police officials
smiled and said their hands were tied
grace was limited to what she could see
from the outside there were two signs in
the window that read mechanic's Help
Wanted and selling out on the outside to
the left of the front door was a narrow
stairwell that sank into the ground and
served as a separate entrance to the
basement grace walked near these stairs
as unobtrusively as possible
grace knew like it or not that all of
her misgivings about Kochi in his store
were all circumstantial
the police had searched the cellar twice
and found nothing but absence the rest
was gossip and headlines
why was Kochi missing because he had
taken the girl because he had been
spirited away by the same fiends who had
taken poor ruth or was he just terrified
of being blamed by proximity perhaps
there were more sinister forces at work
such as the rumored white slavery ring
that stretched all the way down to
Brazil or was this the work of the black
hand there were even rumors that Kochi
had been very friendly with the
motorcycle cops in his neighborhood
grace knew that those questions might be
the most dangerous ones but they still
had to be asked grace paused considering
the options at play in her mind
intersecting like the city itself still
struggling to connect its new boroughs
into one unified whole perhaps Ruth and
Kochi were the happy couple in this
after all that version of the truth
seemed remote but still grace went back
to her office thinking through the heat
trying to come up with a plan when she
got to her office she called her good
friend the private detective named
Julius J Crone Crone was a federal agent
when he was first assigned to grace
during her u.s. District Attorney days
and grace one of the things I found out
she was the first female US District
Attorney this is I think a major
historical point and you have to look
really really really really hard to find
it anywhere it's a major accomplishment
a proud son of Hungary with dark
features and a scar under his left eye
Crone had a keen mind and chomped on
cigars when he was first hired
representatives of the southern
plantation of hired by the government
of a southern plantation offered him a
substantial amount of money for a jury
list on a peonage case Crone smiled and
agreed but not before sending up a sting
in an Italian restaurant with the help
of a seeker of the secret service after
that he was known as the man who could
not be bribed he and grace had been
partners when needed ever since he's
kind of like her Watson except he's
really prone to punching people in the
face
you really these these characters are
not and you know again I hate true crime
but you can't make this up and that
that's what make it makes it so good he
has a scar and an accent and he punches
people in the face at the Hotel
Manhattan on Madison and 42nd
grace-filled Crone in on the particulars
of Ruth Krueger's disappearance over
oysters crow knew about the case from
the newspapers I want you to meet mrs.
mr. krüger the girl's father grace told
her grim friend between sips of tea he
has a mental and physical wreck if this
isn't solved soon he'll be in a
sanitarium when they left the hotel at
8:00 grace gave crone the bulk of the
files she had on the case hundreds of
typewritten pages crone took the pages
home and studied them all night long
making big blue pencil marks over the
most promising leads in the morning he
blinked his eyes took an icy shower and
ate breakfast before leaving chrome
kissed his wife Estelle and his three
young daughters goodbye after what he
had just read he tarried over them a
moment more when Crone arrived at
Grace's office he found her already
talking to Henry Krueger who looked
completely washed of color and form when
grace introduced Crone Krueger's eyes
pleaded at him from under his bushy
eyebrows and bald head mr. Crone he said
won't you find my little daughter
someone who's keeping her she would
never stay away she would never have
gone
way we hope to mr. krüger Crone replied
with his sliding accent he added just
remember that all of the thousands of
girls who disappear every year over 98%
are located Crone managed a persuasive
smile through the lie
yes Henry cried but where Crone had no
immediate answer both Grace and Crone
knew that in the past year 828 people
had gone missing from the city of New
York 244 people had been murdered either
New York is the most criminal city in
the world grace would say or the police
force is inefficient
after Krueger left grace looked at her
right-hand man crony she said you are
the only man I can trust to dig up the
real facts there is something crooked
behind this whole thing for the next
week grace split her time between the
office and searching cellars vacant lots
and asking questions around the
tenements the police made fun of her the
grace was adamant that Ruth was not a
wayward girl who had eloped as a result
of a senseless head every interview she
had with Ruth's friends and
acquaintances had suggested otherwise
and this is I think one of her great
legacies that in the past when a girl
would go missing it was always her fault
and you know to some extent that still
happens but grace was adamant that it
wasn't her fault that she knew that
someone had done this to her and it
changed the whole investigation Krone
had disappeared as well as grace knew he
would going deep into the case when he
finally called grace had started to set
her own larger plan into motion
mrs. Humiston Krone said I've got
something on Kochi an hour later Kron
sat across from grace at the hotel again
he looked over his shoulder and dropped
his voice Crone told grace about someone
he had talked to who used to live on
Cochise Street her name was Madame Maria
and she was Maria and she was a French
actress who lived with her 16 year old
daughter Philippa their house was across
the street from the motorcycle shop when
Philippa's bicycle broke one summer her
mother sent her to get it fixed by
coaching when Philippa came back her
bike was not only fixed but it was white
the girl opened her hand and showed her
mother arose the coach he had given her
another day philippa went over to the
motorcycle store to see if kochi could
attach a small motor to her bicycle
coach he wiped his hands on his rag
looked at her bike and said he'd do it
for her cheap just for her
oh really said her mother when her
daughter told her yes said Philippa
because he told me he likes me as her
mother watched from the window she saw
Kochi and her daughter Philippa going to
the store suddenly she had a sense of
unease and ran down to the street when
she reached ahead of the basement steps
she heard her daughter screaming mother
mother her mother screamed her
daughter's name and she came flying out
sobbing and shaking with terror the
sleeve of her dress had been ripped
loose I could see the spots already
turning blue her mother said from the
grip of the man's fingers I want all
mothers to know she said how easily
these things can happen there was that
man right across the street from us and
yet he dared to commit this deed in
broad daylight within a few yards of our
home I wanted to go at once to the
police and I'm sorry now that I didn't I
had forgotten the name of the motorcycle
man on Manhattan Street until his face
stared at me from the paper finishing
her tea grace was seeing someone new
appear in her mind something worse and
he had been under their faces the whole
time she had a new fact she was now
absolutely sure of this man gray said
should have been behind bars years ago
we'll make up for that said chrome
but they needed evidence to catch the
monster and to hopefully find Ruth alive
they needed to get into that store and
the mysterious cellar beneath it grace
had been thinking about this problem
almost constantly she saw an opening
that wouldn't make them reliant on the
unhelpful police in fact it would
probably be best that they didn't even
know about it she then asked Kron a very
strange pointed question she asked him
if he knew how to fix a motorcycle that
night Kron took out some ragged clothes
and puzzled over a borrowed motorcycle
repair manual he stayed up late with the
aid of coffee and light trying to figure
out how to fix an awl chain drive the
next morning crow knocked on the door at
coachee store when maria kochi answered
crone told her he was here for the job
she looked him over then asked what
experience he had several years replied
Crone quickly looking her directly in
the eyes then get to work mrs. Cochise
said clean out that clogged gasoline on
the red one first Crone pause he had
never monkeyed with a motorcycle before
he had a car of his own and could tinker
it up all right
but he'd have to experiment with the
cycle and he hated these clothes he was
a notorious dresser he always would
always wear these tweed jackets even in
the summer
so in having to dress down for this job
he didn't like it but she was standing
right there watching him what are you
standing there she said Crone heard her
emphasis on there and looked down at his
feet he was standing on an iron grating
that had hot air blowing up from from
the basement
it was late spring so there should be no
need for heat Kron thought he wondered
if there was equipment down there while
I'm looking for a place to hitch my coat
said Kron stalling missus coach he
pointed with her thumb to a nail on the
wall as he hung up his coat Kron asked
is there any other helper here ma'am if
you don't mind my asking I do mind you
asking Maria answered mimicking him
don't ask so many damn questions
and this is actual I'm not making this
all the dialogue in here none of its
made up it's either from court documents
or there's some other stories on it for
a week Julius J Kron the Hungarian
detective who could not be bribed
fumbled and bluffed his way through
motorcycle repairs as Maria coach he
watched over him like a hawk Kron would
commit the bikes maladies to Hart learn
how to fix them at night by reading the
manuals and try to put this knowledge
into effect the next day he had more
than surprising success the more
daunting exercise was dealing with Mrs
Kochi all the while Kron reported back
to grace everything he was learning
about the shop they would need at her
office or in hotels and would pass on
the information the one-story building
was largely taken over by motorcycles
most of their repairs long overdue there
was a workshop in the cellar but it was
only accessible through the outside
stairs in the front
mrs. Kochi never let him go down there
whenever he needed tools she would go
down and bring them up herself Crone
didn't think she trusted him or anyone
for that matter on the fifth day of
Crone's new job as a mechanic a customer
brought in a motorcycle that needed
three of the front wheel spokes replaced
all Crone needed to do was solder it but
the equipment was in the basement
without pause Kron began to put on his
hat and coat
mrs. Kochi stopped him where are you
going now she asked the smithy to get
these spokes soldered you don't need to
go to no smithy mrs. coach she said I'll
take you downstairs and you can use the
heater there Crone put his hat and coat
back on the tack he made sure to control
his breathing and to conceal his eyes
mrs. Kochi wiped her hands and he
followed her outside the shop at the
front side like there were four steps
that led down to the cellar as mrs.
Kochi remained standing on top to watch
the store crone jumped down mrs. coach
he kept an eye on him as he went inside
when Crone entered the basement he tried
to take it in and all he tried to take
it all in as quickly as possible
there was no lavish furnished space
lavish furnished space or medieval
dungeon
there was only a workbench a massive
tool chest
some rags in a corner and the slick
smell of motor oil there were two
windows facing facing the front small
Ally Crone scanned the wooden boards on
the floor for new damage or shiny bright
nails but even the dust was uniform crow
knew that the police had already
searched this room twice don't you see
the heater there in front of you mrs.
Kochi shouted from the stairs there was
a pause Kochi
Crone looked around again for a
footprint or a scuff anything anything
out of the ordinary he started searching
the back wall when he suddenly realized
he had taken too long never mind come on
up mrs. Kochi said quickly take the
spokes to the smithy at that moment
crone was convinced of two things bye
mrs. cochise high-pitched voice one that
there must be some kind of tiny clue in
that basement and two that the jig was
up
chrome grabbed the spokes and scrambled
up the stairs he could hear a customer
in the shop maybe mrs. Kochi just wanted
him out of the cellar rather than leave
him unattended maybe there was nothing
down there after all the tools were
valuable but not as valuable as what he
was looking for there was no secret cell
or hidden door or at least he had not
seen one it was just an ordinary New
York seller maybe mrs. coach he hasn't
had noticed his absence at all but when
he came up the stairs
her eyes were locked on him I know you
now she said you're another of those
detectives that chased poor al away
you're no mechanic you're a hound she
broke down crying get out get out get
out
as Kron was pushed out into the street
he knew he had failed grace her plan had
worked beautifully until he got in that
basement and had blown his cover Kron
slouched inside and walked away from the
store alongside the black cars he was
convinced completely that he had missed
something in that underground room he
understood now he would stop at nothing
nothing to get back to that still space
to find out what really happened to Ruth
Krueger thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so I think we're going to do some
questions if anyone has any
Polly's walking around with a microphone
anyone has any questions or comments or
hi there you mentioned that she
disappeared
and any information at all about where
she ended up and then what happened so
this is a new book for me I mean it just
came out two weeks ago and I'm kind of
in starting to do these readings and
such I'm trying to answer questions but
at the same time not giving out spoilers
because I know I don't like it you know
it's so hard nowadays you know because
everybody you know but I can't answer
your question there's very little
information we have about why she
disappears and I have a theory in the
book as to why she disappears but I can
you know say a few things so she takes
on her final case you know Sherlock
Holmes says his great final case her
final case involves she takes on the US
Army which is not a small enemy and what
happens is is people involved in this
case stretch back to her earliest some
of her earliest cases I think the short
way of saying it is when you're someone
like her who gets a lot done and who is
a woman she made many enemies and I
think at the end of her career the
enemies finally come out
and they they make decisions that get
rid of her and I don't mean to say get
rid of her like you know mafioso get rid
of her
but there's an assassination attempt on
her maybe - I think it's - but I think
her end is in some ways it doesn't
matter you know because she would say it
was the fight that mattered but the end
of her life is I think fascinating and I
think there's like there's these there's
a couple cases she does at the end that
you know again you can't make this stuff
up but it's not a fictional character
and you know I joke around that I hate
through crime but it's I really don't
because it's real you know I mean that
we wish I wish it wasn't real but it is
real so she's not like Sherlock Holmes
who kind of gets through everything and
and everything's happy you know except
for the morphine years but she's a human
being and she has a pretty dramatic fall
at the end of this book very dramatic
hey I have a question about the tone and
the language that you chose to use for
this piece of this this book because you
say it is a mystery in many ways but you
also did so much research from the
papers and all how did you how did you
decide about the voice or did it or did
it find you yeah that's a great question
so I think it's I like putting the
reader there because I know I like that
as a reader so I try to when I do
description I look at a lot of old
photographs so I was lucky I got two
photographs of the store and I promise
you every detail those photographs by
the type of this book like you know the
graham cracker sign and so I don't make
stuff up it's all there but I think that
it rings true as far as the language I
really wanted it to have some of that
you know early you read these papers
long enough and it just starts to leave
its mark you know the language back that
is very fast and there's all these great
slang words so I just kind of used them
as is and I think you know there's
nothing you have to like look up you
know it's all but but they they have a
lot of different terms and strange terms
but I wanted it to have because part of
what I want to investigate is the role
of mass media in this and you know mass
media just takes this story and explodes
it and so I'm interested in does that
make it does that help Ruth Krueger or
does that hurt Ruth Krueger and the
Massa means the newspapers at this time
everything's just this huge big thing so
there's a lot of hyperbole there's a lot
of a big talk but so that's part of it
to it I wanted it to have that kind of
more feeling to it - it's a mystery you
know
I did this because I knew you were all
the way over there what were some the
sources for your research on this book
how deep were you able to go what
avenues did you take yeah that's a great
question too so those of you to do
research I'm you know once I there's two
levels so you once I heard about her
you know you the first kind of alarm
that goes off is well somebody else must
have written a book on her so you
there's that first you know really
fateful google search and I was
astounded there were only like a couple
online articles and you know nothing big
but then I was I was sure I was so sure
that somewhere there was an archive of
her papers of you know she was this big
lawyer the her letters or correspondence
or nothing I looked for a year nothing
nowhere the only thing I found was a
letter she wrote to Amelia Earhart and
it's like six words it's like good luck
and that's it so at that point I
considered dropping the project because
I could I had nothing to work from but
in many ways that kind of resulted in a
better product because what it made me
do was think well if I have no primary
sources are very few why not tell the
story like it was told to a readership
like it was told to people reading
newspapers so once I that kind of
clicked in my head I just read all the
newspapers and I was astounded at the
good stuff they had and people were
telling me well you know it's always all
yellow journalism back then and and it
you couldn't believe any of it but I
found great stuff and I found newspapers
had agreed with with each other but I
also found like I tried to find a grand
jury
I wrote you know a judge in New Jersey
saying you know hey can you release this
grand jury file you know a hundred years
ago and he said no of course I can't but
you know you can't do that
but I found a New York paper that
printed the whole transcript
on the front page so what they were
doing in the papers back then it was the
Wild West but it was it was great for me
so is there's a lot of newspapers
there's a lot of court cases I got lucky
on I found a lot of stories that people
wrote right after this for someone like
the detective magazines some of those
were just totally made-up but others
were spot-on so this gives a real
Frankenstein's monster of stuff but but
nothing really from her I mean the thing
that astounds me to this day is you she
was a lawyer for the majority of her
life and she didn't even leave a well
which is you know again goes to her
mysterious end so yeah that's why I said
you know it's not a biography it's it's
a mystery and you know I like mysteries
butters
you must start fleshing her out in a way
that you almost feel you would hear if
you walk down the street what sort of
things start playing on your mind and
fill in the blanks that aren't there
about her personally yeah so it was this
one was a little harder because there
wasn't enough but there was she had such
a big personality and there was so the
good thing is there were a bunch of big
interviews with her so I could get a
sense of her voice and she was you know
she was always late to court
she was always her favorite store was
Bergdorf Goodman you know and people
would see her there its aren't you
supposed to be in court and she would
you know so okay and she always wore
black and nobody knows why but and in
some of the exchanges she has with
people you know she settled many things
out of court she was one of the the
first to do that on you know this kind
of street level but I think I did get a
good sense of her voice so if I saw her
on the street I think that I don't think
she would surprise me but at the same
time she's kind of endlessly surprising
you know the fact that she would would
go down to the south dressed is at one
point she dresses like a man to enter
one of these camps and then she goes off
to when the president when Teddy
Roosevelt shuts down her investigation
of the slave camps you know instead of
just ducking with her tail between her
legs she goes off to Europe and she says
I'm going to find where this is starting
and she finds this creepy barber shop in
Italy where she finds the person who's
trafficking these workers and in you
know in 1917 they called it white
slavery and which was a you know kind of
a another name for prostitution but you
know it's human trafficking and we have
it today and it's it's the same thing
and she gets it she takes it right to
the source so she's kind of I think I'd
recognize her and I
think she'd be you know I hope she
wouldn't you know sue me or something
because she was a good lawyer but she's
endlessly surprising so nothing would
would ya
with the term fake news getting thrown
around a lot lately on various news
outlets in your reading of all these new
dark news articles from a hundred years
ago do you think there's very much
difference in the way things were
reported then as to now or in a sense
things change but don't change yeah
that's a great cause I've been thinking
about that question a lot so I'm really
glad you asked that that's so when Ruth
disappears the very first articles you
know these really tragic
you know these pictures of her and where
is she gon come home Ruth come home but
once the police kind of give up and they
really give up and there's no clues some
papers just invent them they're like you
know oh she was spotted on a boat going
to Brazil you know she's been bought by
a prince or something you know they're
just literally making it up to some more
papers so there's definitely a lot of
fake news that happened then that you
know I didn't you know I just kind of
chalked it up to the times when I wrote
it and then now you know you see what
goes on now really nothing is has really
changed you know look look so let's sell
some papers you know keep clicking on
this to see what you know your favorite
80s celebrity looks like today yeah
I don't know what's next
I'm working on it but it's interesting
you bring that up because after I did
the book on Superman all these people
are like well the next one's on Batman
right and I said you know and I would
just not tell ya sure sure but I had no
interest in writing about that not I
mean I'd like Batman don't get me wrong
but you know Superman was that was that
was it I I knew I couldn't you know I
just can do it so but the ironic thing
is I wrote about a rich person who shuns
society life wears all black works
outside the law I wrote a book about
Batman except she's a woman and she's
real
so she's better yeah
you said this is a mystery and obviously
we don't know what's happened to her how
long was she active and that you said
that she was most famous across New York
and obviously America but for how long
and then what is your thoughts as to why
so little is known about her today if
being the first woman District Attorney
as you said and all the other things
that she excelled at why do you think we
don't know about her um great question
so she was active you know from one of
the things I really was happy that I was
able to do is is look at her first cases
she does - really she does a death
penalty case in New Jersey where a woman
kills a man who attacks her and in
self-defense but it's 19 you know the
court doesn't see it that way and she's
sentenced to hang and grace takes the
case having never argued right out of
law school having never been in a real
courtroom she takes the case sight
unseen never even met the woman
antoinette told us her name and it's you
know the man who attacked or had a gun
but it disappeared you know so that's
what you need to prove self-defense and
grace finds the gun so there's lots of
budgets portlets are there's um
there's lots of early cases but I the
way it's structured the book as it jumps
around in time because I wanted to show
how the early cases kind of affected her
solving this big case you know any
detective will tell you it's their
experience that makes a good detective
you don't go to school for it it's you
go through case or case and you pick
things from the past to solve the the
present but the second part you know why
did she disappear I think and this is
you know a theory without giving too
much away but it wasn't by accident
again if you make enough people angry
you know they can get rid of you it and
again I don't mean you know get rid of
you but politically
she was silenced and she had a huge
political voice she was in the
newspapers almost every day writing
columns we need to do this to protect
our children and this you know advice
columns and law columns so she was
really silence after this this case with
the army and and I think I say I put
forth a couple of theories in the book
one that there's one person who she
really made mad really made man who she
really was really angry at her for her
whole career and he's one of the most
powerful men of the 21st century you
could 20th century you could you could
argue about let you see who it is but
she makes a lot of people angry and I
think it's because she's a woman she
made the entire NYPD look like fools
when she solved the Kruger case after
she solves that they undergo the biggest
investigation into their department to
date and it makes them look so bad
because it makes them people get fired
right off the bat it makes them not only
you know negligent but it actually shows
evidence of possible being complicit to
the crime itself which is something we
don't want to think about so yeah I
think there's there's there's reasons
that she disappears definitely and and
yeah
and you know it's kind of the ultimate
disappearing act it's disappearing from
history you know
you just mentioned that disappearing
from history was that through design
then I mean you know if things were
possibly removed or something to help
kind of eliminate her from history like
that um that would be really that would
have been a great last chip well I don't
I don't have proof of that you know but
I think the way it happened it was so
abrupt that she was publicly shamed and
disappeared that I think when it happens
that abruptly and it could happen back
then where everything was physical you
know now you can't really erase someone
you know they're always like around on
the internet I guess but don't look up
you know old photos and stuff but yeah I
don't know if it was that sinister but I
don't know that it wasn't there are a
lot of people that did not I mean did
she went after the the army on the eve
of World War one basically
question
one more well thank you so much Brad for
coming tonight thank you for coming
and don't forget to join us in the
rotunda for refreshments and book
signing if you have further questions
[Music]
[Music]